[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
but this time
something just escaped
i just wanted
to
[Music]
know swear
[Music]
[Music]
it was a chinese mistake
[Music]
[Music]
sometimes
[Music]
pathogens get away
chinese
[Music]
look
[Music]
it was a chinese
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so look at me
[Applause]
is
[Music]
[Music]
dot com
[Music]
[Music]
channel
stranger
thank you johnny boy everything's going
to taste like rubber for two months
a little hot a little bit hot blisters a
little bit hot coming in hot uh by the
way we have a lot to get to today uh uh
just an absolute ton
to get to and it's tough to keep track
sometimes of the the gain of function
and you know fauci
uh
he's commonly referred to the science
um
with gain of function so there is
something new that has come out that is
even more damning and i know it's kind
of like russiagate you know people
sometimes they go oh what happened and i
feel like this has been going on for a
long time no there's new information
that is as damning as any that has come
out we'll talk about that also uh voting
i don't know if you know this but if
former vice president joe biden has his
way
and president harris um his word's not
mine
[Laughter]
all references will be available not
only at loudoun.com in this show on
video well so believe your lion eyes and
ears and scent if your uh sense of smell
if you're near uh former vice president
joe biden um
it's the shoes
so
he actually wants to make sure that not
only do we not have the filibuster but
that you never need id to vote again oh
well that's convenient yeah
so i say look i actually agree with that
if you don't need id to purchase a
firearm okay
a six-pack drive a car right check out a
library book right or rent uh uh come on
by the hour
i'd but yeah you don't need id for that
you don't need anything you know you
just need some mayoral position yeah
[Music]
you just need to be in charge of the
next run that was the meeting people
were like i really have behind this uh
kamala what do you think what do you
think she's into power yeah yeah
just get some of that and uh she's like
a pop out book she's like real power
bottom yes yes and but and by the
because she cut she uh she because she
pulls at the bottom
yes that's the bottom of the polls on
the democratic primary she tugs out no
one was less popular
literally they had a stage of everybody
think about that there was bernie
sanders yeah there was swalwell there
was hickenlooper that's right and then
still
kamala harris had to pull back had to
jerk the curtain and peer her ugly face
and remember me yeah don't forget beto
and booker were still alive at that
point falling below them yeah she was
hiding behind beto's quarter pipe
going crazy and i'm reaping all the
benefits i am reaping all the benefits
losing his mind okay so a few things so
let me ask you this comment of the day
this is the best thing you can do when
we're back on youtube by the way monday
through thursday 10 a.m eastern okay
if you don't see us on youtube and we
don't tell you
why we're not here then that just means
uh we're on rumble we're on mug club so
go watch it over there okay
hold on hey gerald honestly i need you
to say go to the journal for a second
304 because i don't know oh oh gross i
had something in my mouth today camera
was like
okay why would you do that to me have
you ever this is what i want you to
comment uh have you ever seen
a sitting former vice president
refer to american citizens as domestic
enemies
and we're going to get to that in a
second because remember when people got
really mad that donald trump was saying
that the liberal media
is the enemy of the president yeah you
know at first it was actually a stalin
quote that they misquoted to him and
then he kind of said it
but
oops i don't disagree for crying out
loud brian williams i mean if he's not
the enemy of the american people then
you can't have enemies right
with friends like him who needs
journalists
so have any um
that's my question for you and of course
there's the promo code uh it's lwc
returns 20 off mug club we'll be doing
another 45 minutes here today and a full
uh show this friday
but we review don't look up
do we have to spoiler alert
it's crap
what happens if we do look so before we
move into all these uh topics and more
uh gerald as here how are you i am well
sir how are you doing i'm doing fine you
know i don't have any of the symptoms
from the uh the omni core virus the only
thing i have left is just being tired
yeah about it right not super run down
like uh less than a cold yeah well
you're tired that's the excuses wife has
been using for months
we got our second kid on the way she has
oh headache she has omicron 10 months
out of the year
i got any of that
might all for that omicron so not when
i'm over no no whoa
hey
jeez what what build bar flying at your
head in a moment why well i think get
roman's gonna become a sponsor soon
enough so that's gonna be everybody this
has nothing to do with your wife by the
way i'm sorry mrs martin we did not mean
anything dave apologize to gerald before
i'm sorry
no you apologize to my wife
i don't have nothing to apologize for i
was implying that she doesn't want to
she doesn't want to have intimate
relations with you which is reasonable
he was implying that he was having
intimate relations with her like she was
some like she was some kind of kamala i
wasn't implying i was telling him about
it well it assaulted me again in your
explanation
i did do that
i did do that i was kidding she likes
them tall yes she does she likes that's
why i wear stilts
[Laughter]
just when you think dave's going to
apologize by the way
there was a santa on stilts i don't know
if they're sorry guys you know what if
you're okay that we went off the rails
this quickly we're gonna get to the meet
smash the like button because this is a
true story there was a santa at you know
they did that tree lighting yeah yeah
there was a santa on stilts and these
were high stilts and i walked right up
to them at this point i was supposed to
low still right yes well yeah there's a
very there are degrees of still that's
true i don't want to this required
talent so
uh i walked right after my dad was in
tears because i had been training muay
thai at this point and i walked right up
to him looked at him and i turned my
hips over like i was gonna leg kick as
stilt right out from under him and he
went
and then he almost fell but i just from
the deke
i'm a child you have an idea how violent
that would be was this santa nine feet
up on stilts if you just swept the legs
i think most people who do stilts for a
living do die in a fake out stilt kick
accident right yes
like the guy who created the segway who
died segwaying off a cliff not the best
he's like i could i just lost control it
was going three miles an hour it's like
i could just jump off
oh he tried to jump off and it followed
him he's like
oh no
oh this is going to hurt at least he
looks cool doing it
like kickflip
you got his pants tucked into his sock a
clip-on tie he's like safety first oh no
what's that an acme cliff
good thing i have a helmet someone who
hits a button an anvil falls on him
so uh also i guess i should introduce
him here now uh he's going to be
at uh the civic auditorium in running
california january 15th january 16th at
the crest theater in san francisco dave
landau how are you sir ahoy good i'm
good i can't complain i
you know i'm living hearts beating i'm
all right so i wanted adam that's about
all you can have fine so uh before i
move on according to this random lady we
want to watch this uh you have to wear
masks while eating now
what you want
what i want you want to ask me where my
mask was
why you don't see it on this bread but
how do i eat with that with a mess down
how am i eating you want me to eat
y'all how are we supposed to eat this
woman gonna come over here ask me how
wine got my mask on mass right here
she's gonna ask me why ain't got no mask
on i'm trying to eat my food now i'm
gonna eat my food
this woman right here gonna add
oh my damn ass how are we going to eat
y'all eating the same damn what man
she thought she had a hood pass with her
one tito glove yeah from michael jackson
they're at a casino right
you know what i love about that is
usually gay black men love fat white
that didn't work out well for me yeah
they sure don't no that's what i love is
you're gonna go up to the sassiest
looking man there yes who looks like the
woman from right now while you're
wearing a couch throw yeah i just think
you're gonna i hate god i hate karen's
like well she she had her mask below her
nose too by the way i don't know if you
saw that why did she have one surgery
was she off her shift at subway yeah
that was her that was her bandit pulling
arm that's true that was her uh slot
hand and by the way when people try and
say like oh it's racist to do voice or
something how did i know when i first
watched that clip within two seconds the
man filming is a gay black man i don't
know his voice yeah
i try not to make those assumptions this
farmer's market chalk demon farmer's
market usda [ __ ] i get the chalk
demon thing i just didn't get the
farmer's market though because white
people go to farmer's markets yeah
like black people saying black people
can't farm i mean they go to urban
farmers markets do that again
i go to urban farmers
yeah let's go yes yeah that's yeah let's
dig that grave one more time
which is by the way where they often
urban farms
all right i got some turnips and some
eggplants and oh that [ __ ] that was my
brother he's right here i forgot that we
put him here in this plot
cheese finding aretha
no
urethra and i got the low max to fix
that [ __ ] whoa now uti it is frosty
sake to me
so before we move on to uh again just
because some people think that i was
lying and i was not
uh while giving a speech on voting
rights in atlanta and by voting rights i
mean no identification necessary to be
very clear otherwise it could because if
you believe in id you're a klansman
uh biden uh his dementia is showing
this week in biden wait if you have a
problem figuring out whether you're for
me or trump and you ain't black
last week president harris and i
stood in the united states capital wait
if you have a problem figuring out
whether you're for me or trump then you
ain't black i mean i don't even have a
note for this
was he ever smart
it's not even the case if you mention
anymore it's just he's an idiot no he's
just well they're they're transitioning
like they've been telling me to start
easing it in there president uh harris
yeah like who told you she did yeah he's
the only person with a 40-year history
of dementia and he's the only person in
an office of power she hasn't slept with
well that's because he physically can't
yeah she's just waiting them out right
yeah
i gotta eat eight blue pills and he's
like i don't know oh i'm taking the
cialis like m m's i think hunter's
taking them replacing them with tic tacs
again well he's putting them in the
swiss cheese holes and smoking them
it's faster blood plasma level the guy
cat couldn't scratch it so i need to
smell a child yes there it is
i need my essence fill up it's like
smelling cells that's what happens every
time he soils himself they just take a
12 year old boy and wait
he's like yogi bear with a pie in the
window so
hey boo boo i think there's a
12-year-old boy
just floating through the air
park rangers
pedophiles
toucan sam yeah
just follow your pedophile nose
minor attracted persons
children are great so um
let me get to the fouchy thing here uh
and i know that this is something it's
it's hard to keep track of for a lot of
people this is what i do for a living
and sometimes i go okay didn't we
already prove that this guy knew about
gain of function let me give you a brief
recap because it happened yesterday
while we were live on air
with yes with rand paul and your point
was the best yesterday by the way about
rand paul and fauci accusing rand paul
of trying to kill him you're like iowa
yeah from iowa from iowa
miles away two thousand miles away was
trying to get he beat aoc's distance he
did yeah yeah exactly a transgender
swimmer could get there faster yeah
on land
he had a gun and was nine states away
yeah that sounds exactly i'm like oh
yeah really tell me more
and there was also a guy with a camp gun
and connected he i don't feel safe
anywhere
oh we had very loud whippets yes
so uh fauci told congress that he never
saw grant money right uh funding the
gain of function research okay you guys
all remember this the house republicans
then released new emails now these
emails made it clear that let me read
the quote for you by january 27 2020 dr
fauci knew that the niaid had funded eco
health the wiv wuhan institute of
biology was a sub-grantee of eco-health
and eco-health was not in compliance
with its grant reporting in particular
that the national infection they knew
that they had gain of function potential
okay for novel back chronoviruses this
is something that you already know i
just want to make sure so you understand
what is new now um the emails also show
that fauci and frances collins colluded
with other scientists
to put down the lab leak theory yeah so
it's not that okay there was funding of
the research and he was warned about it
now there is there's no plausible
deniability because there's evidence all
references available at latter of
credit.com link in the description that
they were saying how do we punt this how
do we get rid of this how do we bury
this um and they did it even though
there were some high profile scientists
in the same email chain who told them
that it was possible
they said 70 30 to 60 40 on it so it
wasn't like a remote possibility that
they were just like hey it's 90 that it
didn't i got like 10 percent maybe that
it did right it was like hey i'm almost
50 50 that this thing may have come from
this lab right yet that's what rand paul
pointed out is like then you put
something out in wired magazine to run
cover right and you came out and said no
and people got kicked off of youtube for
saying this
youtube for saying this yep we got
kicked off youtube for doing this not
people
this guy
exactly well i think mostly it was my
fault yes it was your fault yeah who'd
have thought that of all the hard
strikes two of them were from gerald
yeah it's funny people on the road are
always like you gotta stop getting them
kicked off i'm like literally never work
it's never it's never ever was me it's
never happened
it's just been the cold hard facts that
have gotten us thrown off it's been
gerald you know what it is you know how
we know we're gonna get kicked off
youtube is anytime gerald says like uh
uh something accurate yeah he says hey
can you pull up the cdc stats for a
second well and we're gone what happened
yeah that's weird hey do you know that
it's like 60 40 from this doctor saying
that it was from oh shoot there and by
the way if he's saying 60 40 or 70 30
it's a really dangerous position to take
yeah you know that it's more like it's
probably 70 30 the other way
oh yeah because he's pushing it up yeah
if a doctor is saying like i don't know
i think there's a 30 or 40 percent
chance that maybe it came from a lab
what that doctor is saying is it came
from others
that's why they scribble their names so
they're like that's not my signature on
your brother that oh deed on vicodin
right
for the last time it was methadone i
used to be a viking an addict now i'm a
methadone addict okay i do both well it
improves my high
so high-profile scientists in the same
email chain said look there's a strong
possibility that this came from a lab
and then you have fauci and and francis
collins saying how do we get rid of this
how do we make sure that this doesn't
get out you're about to say something
yeah mission control is saying that one
of the the scientists that was saying
that is the doctor that discovered the
tsar's receptor ah so it's not just
nobody some random doctor no no no yeah
by the way what a miserable existence
that is
they put that on his headstone it's like
discovered the sars receptor yeah yeah
for all the horrible diseases that
everybody hates i'm the reason that
people were locked down in toronto
what happened to him did clinton kill
him well not yet oh
i mean as far as we know there could be
a body double c yeah that's true we
don't know he's breaking his hyoid in a
cell somewhere now uh remember back in
may so these emails were going back and
forth this is what is different fouchy
knew about it these doctors who were
reputable doctors the science as you
would refer to them and also let's keep
one thing in perspective when people say
the science can we all agree when people
say common ground okay i want you to
comment here below because i know that
there are a lot of people who are who
are liberal
you watching right now who watch this
show our number one uh city where people
watch this is los angeles like san
francisco yes yeah because we have a lot
of a lot of people who watch right now
you're conservative living in
in blue states uh yeah fox news caters
to fly over a country if i hear rascal
flats life is a highway one more time
i'm gonna blow my brains out don't do it
but uh a lot of you i understand you
sort of are misfits and so a lot of you
who are watching right now i'm speaking
to you the individual you're probably a
conservative who lives in a relatively
blue area or in a blue area of work
so um this is something that i would
hope everyone can agree with if we're
talking about common ground the science
don't you want as many reputable
scientists as possible do you want it to
be a dictatorship does the science mean
fouchy because in this in this case we
have many doctors now we know he's
already discounted the other doctors
from uh from stanford from harvard from
oxford you know some doctors have
actually seen patients we know that
they've tried to revoke the actual uh
medical license of dr peter mccullough
who was on the show what nine months ago
we know that there were doctors who were
banned who said early on that we're
seeing people in our practice in
southern california and uh this uh this
covid19 is does not have the two to four
percent mortality rate that was being
touted at that point we know that we've
discounted those doctors but what about
in this case the doctors who were on a
closed email chain with fauci meaning he
was fine with it he was fine with it at
that point this input was to be included
until he didn't like what they had to
say
shouldn't we all agree that science
should include as many valuable
scientific minds as possible so let me
just establish that that's what's
different now keep in mind this is also
why it matters back in may of 2020 which
would have been again we're talking
about these emails you can see what
happened he already knew about this this
is when fauci claimed pretty
definitively that it was not meaning it
the virus uh man-made and it had it had
not escaped in a lab this is may of 2020
when these emails were going on which we
now know
if you look at
the evolution of the virus in bats
and what's out there now
it is very very strongly leaning towards
this could not have been artificially or
deliberately manipulated
apparently 60 is very very strongly
a number of very qualified
evolutionary biologists have said that
everything about the stepwise evolution
over time
strongly indicates that it evolved in
nature and then jumped species
someone will say well
a sandwich that i carried out of a leg
put it in the lab and then it escaped
from the lab
but that means it was in the wild to
begin with
so that's why i don't get what they're
talking about if it isn't manipulated in
the lab
and you're trying to say it escape from
the lab
then how did it get in the lab
it was in the well you were in the wild
two ones except you've spent the last 90
years in a cubicle what is he trying to
say at some point there was something in
nature and then then there was a lab and
we uh mutated it into an ungodly virus
that didn't exist in nature so i think
that we can all agree this is uh from
natural causes why is he laughing i know
he's like oh boy then it got out of the
lab and then everybody got sick yeah
he's the kind of person who would look
at phil hartman's body and be like
natural causes yeah could have been the
vid yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah his wife
was all hopped up on covey lorena
bobbitt his penis went out of uh it was
thrown from the camry from natural
causes well actually dr fauci would mean
that it's been in the wild and it hasn't
done anybody any harm until you brought
it to a lab in the middle of a hugely
populated place next to a wet market
right maybe that's something we should
look at even if it wasn't manipulated
like there's a point
you know did he become
superhuman when we forged the adamantium
to his exoskeleton i'm not sure but at
one point he was existing without us
i tickled him without gloves yes
just don't piss off the virus and put it
in a second i had lunch you made a good
point too what's the about fauci's uh
fauci's wife yeah fauci's wife uh so
it's really interesting she's actually
the chief of ethics for the nih that's
his wife wow so great chief of ethics it
looks like will ferrell playing janet
reno looks like one of the looks like
one of the king friday puppets from mr
rogers
oh lord on a finger like is that ad
hominem yep that is as good as he looks
for 80
i thought he could have done better that
is the grossest sex
can you imagine oh
this feeling occurs nowhere in nature
that's why
you guys making viruses he's just trying
to get rid of that have some soup
how did she beat it again oh
he's squeezing his eye into her coffee
everybody's sick but yo wow jeez damn
that natural immunity that's the thing
you know when you tell your wife you're
gonna take her to heaven and back he's
like i'm gonna take you to the lab ah
oh
yeah
look at my baseball card yeah
that's what he's doing he has a mirror
on the wall but he plasters it with his
fake baseball cards because that's
it's like it's like fouchy cialis look
at myself now i'm ready
i've killed kids before wait till you
see what i leave on your chest oh
come on
oh come on now i'm sorry
comment below if you don't
don't comment ladies and gentlemen we
are a christian men on this show and
this man is not hey she's cute on cnn i
actually did that in the most classy way
i think yes you could all right so look
she was actually the chief of bioethics
at the nih yeah which sounds strange
leaving my mouth chief yeah chief of
bioethics yeah bioethics by chance and
maybe she didn't look i'm not gonna i'm
not gonna get into conspiracy theories
here but
those are the people who make sure that
the things that you're doing are ethical
right
well not if you agree some good well
would uh would a bioethicist by any
other name be as incompetent i'm just
curious so she gave a lecture titled
research ethics and the nih this is not
a joke and the nih was the one who
approved gain of function grants to eco
health but her husband put dogs heads in
cages to be
eaten by flies
[Music]
uh yeah it's ethical yeah totally fine
there's no there's nothing to see
oh by the way we're gonna have judge
fauci we're gonna have the science on
the show tomorrow really he will be on
the show i don't know why he keeps
coming on i love it well i think it's
because he's in science yes he is the
science you need to spread the sciences
far and wide yeah i'm johnny apple
science look at me
it's like i've been condemned to roam
the earth with uh a pumpkin head filled
with science for the rest of my life and
it's the fouchy lantern the or the
science lantern doesn't he seem like
adult butters yes kind of like like if
professor chaos became
function in a lab oh boy i'm going to
get grounded oh boy
i'm in a lot of trouble for this one
there's a lot of trouble for this one i
have to go have sex with my wife oh
gross oh
are you sure you're a girl
that was like a blend of butters in ben
shapiro
well i could see both so the difference
is ben shapiro's wife is absolutely
stunning well and very talented and very
talented and a doctor no
actual doctor yes an actual doctor
i you know what i hey you know what ben
shapiro guys comment below i would his
wife has kept
her life private and rightfully so yeah
i would love to interview an actual
practicing physician like ben shapiro's
wife and see what she thinks about this
someone who has stayed out of politics
because people don't like we joke about
it she's actually she's very qualified
and she's she's very she's very good
looking she's very smart i remember the
first time when i met ben shapiro and he
was just uh you know he was my lawyer
and he was so incredibly off-putting
that
[Laughter]
i then met his wife and it was one of
those things where i thought well okay
he has a plane
he's got something then i realize you
know he's charming yeah he's a nice guy
does he still practice law
not so much i mean i don't think i mean
i know he's capable of it yeah of course
he's like you know he'd give kurt
russell the computer wore tennis shoes
to run for his money so that's true
speaking of uh
running for money um new york city i
don't know if you know this is uh
horrible there's a new york city
marathon does anyone get money for the
marathon yeah
there's one person who gets money in
like 45 000 losers well pretty much
that's when people craft themselves at
the end of it yeah and they're not
buying
themselves watching
it yeah they're bloody tape nipples yeah
yeah
oh that's good during coven you're raw
nipples raw bloody tape good for you you
practice to get raw nipples yeah and you
look like a famine victim that's people
like i'm healthy i'm a marathon runner
like really yeah
you look like the the suntan addict lady
before the food the eating disorder got
the better ever all right so look new
york city wear one glove to hold water
and go where's your mask right yes
exactly bother gay men and day off at
subway so the new york manhattan uh new
york i repeat myself the manhattan d.a
this is the new d.a there uh alvin bragg
uh he's instituted a set of you guys all
know that new york sucks right just to
be clear oh yeah i live there yeah you
know that it's very violent and you know
there's this catch and release and the
cash bail yeah so you would think okay
they're going to straighten up and fly
right they've learned from their
mistakes they saw a population decrease
right whereas places like texas red
states are seeing an increase there's a
direct and i know i've taken humanities
101.2 in college correlation doesn't
equal causation i think it does when you
look at every single liberal [ __ ]
and they're shrinking and then every
single red state is growing to a
significant degree and by the way the
liberal politicians like aoc are
vacationing in red states along with the
governor of michigan they lock down
their states and they themselves go to
red states the same thing is happening
with new york here's the thing you would
think they would be learning from it but
in new york the new d.a alvin bragg he's
now instituted some new policies
which will decriminalize i know you're
thinking like harsher penalties no it
decriminalizes
everything
manhattan's district attorney alvin
bregg says his office will no longer
prosecute crimes like marijuana
misdemeanors prostitution and fair
evasion bregg thinks longer sentences do
not deter crime or make society safer
and in low-level store robberies lesser
charges if a suspect
displays a dangerous instrument but does
not create a genuine risk of physical
harm why did you decide that your office
would no longer prosecute the crimes
that we listed there just a minute ago
and how will this bring more safety i'm
lazy
so i was elected to deliver safety and
justice for all and we we made these
plans clear and and manhattanites
responded resounding i was caught in
river montage so you know we've got work
to do and this plan is going to make us
safer in and of itself i love hookers
but it sounds like some [ __ ] comments
i've done throughout my career yeah work
you should be proud of now it should
also be noted he's not entirely easy on
crime because he uh has installed the
new subway in new york subway safety
guardians
but look look they keep the so it's the
bro it's the broken uh ski mask theory
yeah now one thing i wanted to go back
to tim the tool man here he's and by the
way show him some love he's new here on
the tricaster yeah with quarterback
do we have that clip again when he he
mentions he's talk he mentions i think
he was talking about weapons
what did they call them uh dangerous
instruments can you play that again
and in low-level store robberies lesser
charges if a suspect quote displays a
dangerous instrument but does not create
a genuine risk of physical harm oh okay
is that all it is now we're referring to
it as dangerous instruments oh i don't
know
oh
what just happened oh i don't know if
they're that dangerous is that was that
a
i said no more dangerous no more
dangerous instruments in the studio do
you think you're at genuine risk of harm
i don't think it's genuine
oh my god yeah that's no yes it's
genuine guys let's put a lit let's put
an end to this
i took before we get to the woodwinds oh
listen
oh
i felt
none no more felt good
you feel alive dave i think dangerous
instruments because
a dangerous instrument what was he doing
well he was playing he was playing his
uh sig sauer like a piccolo so i uh
wasn't entirely sure yeah yeah he was
playing as smith he was doing doing the
oboe with the smith and wesson and there
was a cobra coming out of a basket what
is that dangerous instrument highway to
the danger zone yes yeah yeah he was ash
yes yeah he was bowie knifing kenny
loggins
so i have a question a guy standing next
to me with a hatchet threatening me
isn't producing genuine threat of harm
no like in what scenario is he just a
friend well it depends does is the
hatchet accompanied by a triangle
i don't i like that he's like look we're
going to ease up on goofy crimes like
human trafficking and violence yeah
i don't know why i'm hired and weapons
yeah any basically any crime that
involves weapons
you know and this is something else
but if you don't have a mascot if you
don't have a mascot we're gonna lock you
away and throw away the key can you
believe this for a second they just said
their theory
is
longer sentences and punishments do not
deter crime
then why have any punishments why have
any sentences isn't the whole point to
to sentencing to putting someone in
prison to deter crime i am not of the
school of thought people well we focus
too much on punishing and not enough on
rehabilitation there needs to be both
yeah but there does need to be some
punishment i mean are you going to tell
me that punishment doesn't deter crime
at all you're going to tell me that the
fact that there are no punishments or
consequences in new york city right now
has nothing to do with the skyrocketing
violent crime rate i i just is anybody
actually buying this i could present you
stats and i could present you resources
and you could check the references at
laterallycrowder.com and we do provide
them every single day but do i really
need to to convince you that manhattan
is now a more dangerous place because
they aren't sentencing criminals for
committing crimes being locked up is a
punishment there's no doubt about it but
they also do need to focus and i do
agree with that a little bit on
rehabilitation because that should be
part of the entire process right
i think it works better than like hey
let's just uh say no bail and let them
all back out and say give it the old
college right yeah or or even it's
better than in san francisco where it's
well if it's not over 900 and something
dollars then i mean what are we talking
about here yeah well i guess they assume
that criminals can't do basic math like
i was going i was gonna steal three
thousand dollars worth of equipment but
i guess i can't divide by three huh i'm
gonna straighten up and fly right come
back three times
actually if you've ever been to like a
walgreens you really do have to put a
very little effort into stealing nine
hundred dollars worth of stuff have you
seen those prices it's like supermarket
sweep you just make sure you get as much
of the ding you're done yeah bring a
friend that's 1800 bucks right there not
if you're jumping over the prescription
counter well you can make yourself a
fine killing yes you can new york
businessman now uh let me be clear too
this is not all that new york city has
made legal for residents uh you can also
uh vote now even if you're not uh uh a
resident oh so residents can commit
crimes and non-residents can
commit crimes well i'm glad they're
still using that policy yeah exactly i
mean because
okay word play here
used to be a crime to vote if you were
not a resident ah right so non-resident
so that's just no longer a crime
you just vote it's like wait hold on a
second i wasn't a resident and it was
illegal for me to vote before right okay
but
but you can now
oh
so it's no so the crime just disappeared
yeah like all of them you know like
prostitution or dangerous instruments
it's a whole new soft on crime approach
here we hope you like it uh tell your
friends about manhattan so 800 000
non-citizens will now be able to vote
in new york city elections 800 000
non-citizens
don't don't forget the dreamers by the
way four more years the reason they
included dreamers is don't derm this
hasn't passed yeah the dream act didn't
pass they were saying potentially
affected by the not past dreamers act i
was like okay so this is just anybody i
have a dream a vote by mail
that i would present no identification
they're just not counting crime anymore
it's still happening i have a dream of
voting twice well is it a crime if it's
no longer a crime ah
like looking this good yeah you know
what new york is a city of riddles
you are so glad i don't live there right
now you are a mysterious puzzle that
can't be solved manhattan until someone
says like oh yeah how about we just make
it illegal to hurt people again
that's absurd
why would you you may have sex only for
money and hurt each other yes
that's the deal guys progress yeah
let's just keep the brass instruments
out of the violence or you can hurt
someone you've paid to have sex with
right or you can hurt you know citizens
of the entire city by voting when you
have no business being there in the
first place the point is the choice is
you
two non-residents
20 junked-out homeless guys just writing
yes next to sex
[Laughter]
hey uh by the way before we move on from
this uh i don't know if you know this
but crowdershop.com we have a lot uh
yeah we have a lot available there
because uh for a while there was a you
know there was a supply chain destroyer
i don't know supply chain disruption ah
really not so much anymore you go to
crowdershop.com and hey dave i don't
dave
wait i'm on you
wait i'm on you
we're each other
so uh let's move on to the voting rights
uh here is uh yeah i'm dave oh no see
i'm dave now no all that look all that
liquor over there and i can't i can't
touch a drop because i'm an addict
i eat hard-boiled eggs oh whoa that's
yeah steve cholesterol problem yeah
sorry what
no i'm you i said
i'm dave i'm not i'm not yeah what
stephen
i work with children what'd he say no i
am the steven we'll
so
biden gave a speech this is the thing
does anyone actually leave does anybody
actually believe part of what that
voting
uh
that the act of voting requiring id is
racist i don't know like this is one the
only people who i see saying it are
democrat politicians and a few blue
check marks i don't see any black people
saying it racists are saying it
yes
seriously well yeah but that's what i
said yeah
so
yesterday during the voting rights
speech
it's not your right if you're not a
citizen yeah during this steal the vote
speech okay when people say like look
i'm not saying that this wasn't in the
past the most free and fair election in
history right and i'm not saying that
going forward allowing people without id
to vote will uh be anything other than
the most free and fair and secure
elections in history i just want to be
really clear youtube
uh again we're always on rumble if that
results in you know a problem which it
could um
so i want to be clear because this sort
of stems from georgia right everyone's
been going after georgia for a while but
now you're talking about former vice
president biden wanting to nationalize
these leftist utopian policies in their
minds for voting
and i'll explain to you exactly what
they are but first let's go to the
speech from former vice president biden
where he actually called opponents of
his bill
domestic enemies
and and i think somewhere compare we'll
just watch
i will not yield i will not flinch i
will defend the right to vote our
democracy against all enemies foreign
and yes
domestic do you want to be the sign the
side of dr king
or george wallace
do you want to be in the side of john
or bull connor
do you want to be the side of abraham
lincoln or jefferson davis
this is the moment to decide
i'm just really glad he didn't say
airplane
so he i just like how everybody's like
who right now
that was out of speech hold on democrats
dave
i'm gonna fight
because i'm a i could be a regular billy
kahn
uh huh what
i'm a primo carnera you know
no i don't no okay so look he's pushing
the freedom to vote act and let me
explain to you guys what this is uh you
can go to congress.gov we have all of
the references available um what are the
major changes first off this wants they
want to federalize yeah the elect
control process control all of it where
states and i understand the argument to
it when you have states like
pennsylvania this last election where
you basically created laws last minute
that went against their own state's
constitution and then the
court said well it's too late now
all right we screwed up we trusted you
so uh they want to federalize basically
these the way of conducting elections
which of course
flies in the face of checks and balances
and why we have states to begin with and
what will it include it mandates
no excuse vote by mail right in every
state
in other words if a state says you know
what we want you to have a reason to
vote by mail because we've had problems
with voting by mail as many states have
there have been elections that have had
to be changed i'm not talking about the
2020 nationals no i never would say that
but before that there were elections in
new jersey there were elections in texas
there were elections that had to be
changed because there were errors in
mail-in voting and states said you know
what we people need to have a reason
well now the biden bill that he's
talking about for black people of course
is
no all states have to have no excuse
voting by mail okay it also forces
states to allow people to vote
without id
they can cast a provisional ballot with
just an affidavit
and they're not going to lie we trust
why would a criminal lie no that no no
no they don't there's penalties yeah
well no hold on there's not penalties
yeah anymore hey hold on a second wait a
second wait a second wait a second so
it's an affidavit right yes okay so
we're taking their word for it
because it could be they if they're
committing a crime there's a punishment
right is there a punishment for let's
say someone not being a legal resident
no what if you what's the punishment uh
they signed an affidavit right but if
they're not a resident uh-huh do they
get punished well that's not a crime huh
i don't understand you're not supposed
to
it also makes automatic voter
registration the national standard keep
in mind i was registered to vote in
several states don't know what happened
with one of my
votes we did a whole segment on that it
also requires same-day online
registration
and it prevents states from blocking
this is something important to prevent
states from blocking donations of food
or water to voters in line and this is
how democrats frame it they say oh look
republicans don't want people in line to
vote to uh be able to have water that's
not true they don't want people to be
able to go and bribe you with food and
water and sandwiches and ipads that's
the point is you can't solicit anyone in
a voting line this bill would make it
federally
illegal for states to say no foul play
here at the voting lines yeah there's
nothing that prevents like you said for
the poll workers from putting water out
or something like that they just didn't
want put it this way this will make
democrats happy they didn't want
somebody handing out maga hats and
voting lines right that's exactly what
the states were making sure of that's it
yeah if you hand me sandwiches and water
and an ipad i'm going to be like yeah
i'll vote for you
dave's going to stand in line again to
get a second eye yeah second you want me
to vote for kamala harris let me tuna on
rai all right now you've done it that's
my weak spot what's that the new tuscan
parmesan well okay quiznos toasts it can
i play minecraft on this yeah
now finally here's something else to the
bill would uh
this is what's concerning again it
sounds good just like this idea of pro
choice
it doesn't make any sense when you
actually understand it common sense gun
control will ban pretty much every
handgun that people here own when you
look at what they're discussing so here
they say uh this bill would ban the
dissemination of false information is
their word used to deter eligible voters
and by the way who's an eligible voter
uh anyone including people who live in
honduras now
who would determine false information
keep that in mind and this is the thing
when fauci who's unelected has
determined what is
true what is false information and we
now know that he was given information
from other qualified scientists we just
discussed this and he said you know what
no i am the science i'm going to declare
the lab leak theory false and then who
goes along with it facebook youtube
twitter
99 of all information that's controlled
here's the thing for a conspiracy and
i'm not a conspiracy theorist this is
the litmus test for me with a conspiracy
theory how many people have to be
involved for it to work area 51 there's
a janitor somewhere who's going to talk
but in this case if you federalize
elections and they say by the way we get
to determine
what is uh considered misinformation oh
you know what was misinformation
dave going to actual addresses that
don't exist where from which people
voted in in the defense of that though
it was only 100 of them yes it was only
100
of the suspected addresses that weren't
real honestly like at number six i'm
like am i gonna get murdered right like
at first i'm like maybe one of them and
then i was like this is terrifying yeah
it's absolutely petrifying so this is
one of those things yeah there shouldn't
be misinformation i understand it but
how many things six months ago were
considered misinformation that are now
true right remember misinformation was
if you're vaccinated you can't catch
covet and you can't transmit it you were
banned if you said that under biden's
laptop right and yeah look information
banned by facebook banned by uh twitter
yeah new york post right well it's not
like junior giuliani had it and was like
you can just look at this and right like
no no we don't know
well look at the stuff that they left up
that they didn't consider misinformation
the russian prostitute scandal right the
whole russian collusion scandal right
all the the documents that we saw was
like come on guys
don't give that control to anybody who's
doing it right now that donald trump
that donald trump praised white
supremacists that's not labeled
misinformation he said i'm not saying
neo-nazis who should be condemned
totally if you if that's not clearly
enough of a condemnation then then a
condemnation
clear enough does not exist that's the
issue and that's why you need to stop
apologizing to these people this is what
happens as they go oh misinformation no
look nothing that we are delivering here
is misinformation it is correct
information and it's correct information
that some people don't like okay you can
catch the virus if you're vaccinated
we're allowed to say that now we weren't
allowed to say that six months ago right
uh and omnicore variant is definitely
less lethal than delta uh as we know now
they're we've had the highest case load
and we haven't had uh the same kind of
proportional uh increase in death rates
we've had an increase in deaths but not
compared to the delta variant i think
people should be excited about that
people should be excited it means that
hurting
oh that was also misinformation heard
immunity a long time no no no that
doesn't exist we don't know your own
immune system is certainly not something
and we and we've never promoted that
because i i know for sure because i went
to the website where they did have it
but then they deleted it so i know that
it never existed no exactly also by the
way it's misinformation to say that they
changed the definition of immunization
well they would never do that they would
never do that it's not like we have time
machine where we showed you them
changing the definition of immunization
and by the way they had to go back and
that episode where ralphie was sick and
magic school bus yes son ghosted
misinformation can't do that really yeah
i knew i should have stayed home today
so this bill sucks
and i don't like it uh you guys can
comment as to why you dislike it most
but of course uh this is why biden and
it's not even popular by the way voter
id is popular with black people yeah
voter id is popular with uh latin
americans what do we say hispanic latin
americans they prefer
they love that next their favorite
everyone loves that yeah absolutely
that's the way you win the hearts of
macho hispanic men yes is force a term
on them yes
you will be called this yes oh really we
will
my name is keith your name is latinx my
name is
all right
so kamala and biden since this is
unpopular
and it's wrong and it's racist and it's
all these things what do they want to do
what do they want something smart no no
oh in order to ram it through
ramming speed let's get rid of the
filibuster oh
the constitution of the united states
gives the congress the power to pass
legislation
and nowhere
nowhere
does the constitution give a minority
the right to unilaterally block
legislation
let the majority prevail
and if that very minimum is blocked
we have no option but to change the
senate rules including getting rid of
the filibuster for this
yeah he thought he could get rid of the
filibuster by metamucil
half the people behind him are like why
are you clapping right yeah
no it's not clapping those are my balls
that's like the thing on the desk that
never stops when it's
i get up in the morning and they just
swing a linga ding-a-ling
maybe if your proposals were more
popular here's the thing they want to
get rid of the filibuster because a
filibuster is a failsafe when people
[ __ ] about gridlock you should be on
your knees thankful for gridlock the
whole reason that we have these systems
of checks and balances in place is so
that it is not as easy to fundamentally
transform the country when i say this to
people sometimes i get surprised when i
say actually no the united states is the
longest standing uh constitutional
democracy whatever you say
constitutional republic yeah basically
free country with the current system of
government that exists in the world to
go what or democracy what about france
what about john arkansas yeah do you
have any idea how they fundamentally
transformed their system it's not the
same system of government because it
hasn't worked because they didn't create
a system of government that says all
right we need limitations on the powers
that be what did he just say he just
said majority majority a majority
majority no that's why we're not a
democracy guess what just voting by
majority that's mob rule that's mob rule
that's not what this country is if you
like bob rule go over to australia where
well i don't even think there was a vote
but you can put people in concentration
camps i'm sorry trailer parks as they
quarantine for 14 days
is frequently on her knees well listen i
don't necessarily know that that's the
case except i do well the last time i
checked a 50 50 split in the senate
doesn't make either party technically in
the minority no saying that 50 senators
disagree out of 100. he's going by
fouchy math she is used to that split in
half that is not math
that it's not math no it is not the math
he is the science not the math here's
the thing too by the way the longest
filibusters in history
ever two okay strom thurman before we
became an anti-racist republican back
when he was a democrat and robert byrd
and they were both democrats and they
were both against the civil rights act
and if you look at the total time of
filibuster spent the democrats have the
corner on that they filibustered more
than republicans historically they just
don't like it at this point when they
want to ram through unpopular
unconstitutional voting bills this is
the problem they want the filibuster
when it suits them and historically it's
overwhelmingly suited them now they say
you know what we're not able to
transform not only the will of our party
but we need to ram through something
that is uh
actually against directly goes against
the will of the people that's also
what's interesting
when joe biden says the majority okay
now it wouldn't be right for the
majority of american citizens to simply
vote to take away somebody else's right
let's say you have uh let's say you have
a majority of americans who vote to take
away your right to speak well you can't
do that no we have the constitution
you're not allowed to do that the rights
the majority do not trample the rights
of the minority that's why we have a
constitutional republic however
former vice president joe biden when he
says the majority here's what's scary
he's not even talking about your will
he's talking about the majority of elite
politicians and unelected bureaucrats
when he says there shouldn't be the
right of the minority to stop the
majority the majority of americans want
some kind of voter id the majority of
americans think it's already required
you're saying the republicans shouldn't
have the right to block uh the majority
of democrats which by the way also goes
against both
the majority opinion in the united
states and of course infringes upon the
right of both the majority and minority
well we're talking about the american
public so let's be really clear here
when he uses the term majority he's
talking about the democrat party and
it's a 50 50 split right you know who
else agrees with you that uh that the
filibuster should stay in place
former vice president joe biden uh
current leader chuck schumer i think
actually did a video on it in 2017
saying that you cannot get rid of the
filibuster back when he was using it for
his own purposes and also nancy pelosi
has spoken on it so there's some really
high profile people out there that that
are on our side good people thank god
yeah i mean now they're not because they
they just want power but before they
were you know i felt like i was on a
roll and now you just made me filibuster
ah
well doesn't nancy pelosi look like she
should have a trach hole under that
scarf and she's weird she doesn't oh she
does not oh she doesn't no she doesn't
just feel like she'd be in one of those
commercials where she's like this is my
life now i used to eat 25 ice cream in a
forty thousand dollar freezer don't do
it you can end up like ah i still buy it
it's my freezer of dreams so yesterday
cnn two they discussed uh voting rights
groups boycott of biden's speech which i
know you're saying a second why would
they of course cnn is going to cnn and
make it a take a guess take a guess
racist racial oh
yeah with a 50-50 shot either racial
issue or homosexual issue this time
either way
yeah well the optics of this right now
look terrible
stacey abrams here we have the country's
most famous and arguably one of the most
effective voting rights activists who is
skipping a speech by the president on
voting rights in her home state
historically we've faced this before as
a democracy in the 19th century
during reconstruction the parties were
realigned in in that historical context
so the republican party was the party of
civil rights the democratic party was
the party of the racial status quo and
what we did in that context was we
really faltered we allowed voter
suppression to be the law of the land
now it's really easy to take that gay
black man at his word here's the thing
uh wait a second
it was so it was democrats
overwhelmingly who voted the civil
rights act uh
oh no wait no no that was also still
republicans
where's the party switch
anytime it's here's the thing it's not
that when you say now republicans for
example oppose affirmative action or
racial quotas it's not that the
republicans who are the party of freeing
the slaves the republicans who are the
party of the civil rights act it's not
that the republicans became racist it's
that your policies like racial quotas or
assuming that black people can't procure
id are racist republicans have remained
non-racist you're still the racist
despite your lisp yeah well and you're
you're like the i hate to say it like
you're the master of the plantation
racist you're like they can't do it
without me racist yes you're the mint
julep on the porch yeah it's low
expectations that these people need
otherwise they cannot possibly survive
in this world yes racist that's exactly
what it's like it's like a plantation
owner in his sears sucker suit drinking
a mint julep cracking the whip on his
slaves going like i won't have any
racism around here i won't hit yeah
that's your candy
fanning himself yes well he'd probably
have something i had a lovely day now
here's something else i was asking for
slaves you remember yesterday when i was
asking for this ad yeah from cnn yes
well we found it so i had heard it i was
cnn was on in the background yeah and i
said surely this can't be now let me set
the stage here
because
i was listening to it and at first i
thought oh no wait they're going to try
and compare this to january 6th because
they compare a lot of like big days in
history as far as war yeah
but no they took a left turn okay
and went to uh voter id being racist
this is not a parody commercial to try
and convince you
to support
the federalization of elections
requiring no voter id uh that was
running on cnn here
on a far away beach the generation
called our greatest
saved the world from tyranny
in an office we know as oval a new
generation president faced down an
imminent threat of nuclear war
on a bridge in selma alabama the
preacher of his time marched us straight
to passing voting rights for every
american right at a gate in west berlin
a late generation american president
demanded an enemy superpower tear down a
wall
and liberate a continent
american generations answering the call
of their time with american ideals
freedom
liberty
justice
for today's generation of leaders the
call has come again to protect our
freedom to vote to fortify our democracy
by passing the freedom to vote act and
the john lewis voting rights act because
america we are not going back we are
going power
[Music]
yeah what are you a shark i can't go
back
what is
what did i just see you just saw a pile
of festering [ __ ] well how about we add
what these people did for the country
assassinated assassinated almost
assassinated yes exactly
and by the way that was uh because when
i first heard it i thought i heard it
just you know in the next room i thought
it was uh was mlk junior no it was uh
that was louis yeah keep in mind now
look can you guys see this uh this
picture here of andrew breitbart uh
i was a i was a club comic before andrew
breitbart gave me a shot to write on his
website big hollywood there was a time
when the when it was uh i believe it was
clyburn and lewis
who walked up the congressional steps
and this is when they were trying to
paint the tea party as racist for
opposing barack obama and they claimed
that people spat on them and called them
the n-word john lewis said this clyburn
said this and this is sort of at the
dawn of smartphones and you can watch
the footage where everyone has their
camera phones on and you can watch
footage from every single
point of their march up those steps
and there's never an n word uttered
andrew breitbart offered a hundred
thousand dollars to the united negros
college fund for anyone who could
produce any evidence
none whatsoever so the guy who lied
about being called the n-word because
people were opposing record spending
this is what the tea party was this is
the guy who is now saying by the way
unless you support this voting rights
bill uh it's racist we will not go back
we are going forward
yeah everything okay every bit of this
is framed as racist voter suppression
right that's the only way that they can
get this through you don't my favorite
kind of suppression
exactly you don't want every single
possible person like they're going to do
in new york to be able to vote you want
to make sure you balance making sure
people can vote right that's primary
right underneath it is it has to be
secure
that's all these states are really doing
now you may disagree with some policies
in some states because you don't like
how they're doing it or they're moving
days and hours around but they're trying
to secure the elections if you cannot
audit an election and the public does
not believe the election is secure you
might as well not have elections this is
one of these areas too where people i
always say there really is no
conservative uh wing in other countries
like in european countries in canada
that being said these countries that are
far more liberal it's absurd to them
that you would be able to vote by mail
without any form of id yeah it's a
non-option it's something that vladimir
putin would propose right because he's
just filling the ballots out anyway and
everybody knows it right yeah
oh look look we found a 75 million more
votes for me everybody
writes like me that's it i have i had no
idea we had so many uh vladimir does
here in russia and only people who vote
against me were [ __ ] riot but they were
late so hey that's me
now
you've been the roast yes
to be fair
that ad isn't totally wrong now what do
i mean by this
by the way buckle up
uh
i don't have a seat belt yeah well you
know what that's just your chair oh so
the country did have racist problems
there are there's it's i don't want to
say this country is rooted in racism
that's not why this country was created
racism was something that existed for a
very long time in the world in the world
and then we ended it pretty quickly in
this country when you look at it
historically put it this way at the very
least much more quickly than the native
americans who never ended tribalism and
the idea of racial inferiority the
entire time they were here so when
people say give it back to first nations
well which one the one who raped that
first nation or the one who raped that
second nation or the one who scalped
this nation they believed that certain
tribes were inferior now you see them as
looking the same but keep in mind the
algonquins and the iroquois would
obviously be far more different than a
white american and a black american so
racism existed
we didn't create it we ended it pretty
damn quickly but there are some roots of
racism in this country in the sense that
there were some there were some
organizations the kkk i don't think
anyone here would ever defend the kkk
but the kkk
that being said
is not what you think it was far be it
for me to defend the kkk i'm not
defending the case not at all but what i
am saying this will never be taken out
of context you'll never be taken out of
context
is
people don't really know the history of
how it started
things sometimes
get out of hand okay that's all i'm
saying okay
sometimes things get out of hand can we
all agree with that that happened uh
yeah yeah
this branch is yeah so a hand you get
things out but here's the truth these
are the you can references are available
at lidar with crowder.com you ever you
ever look at the kkk names and by the
way like robert byrd second hot longest
filibuster ever this guy was this guy
was a very highly ranked clansman he had
clan dental in a company car aren't
there like grand wizards and scientists
there's an assaulted cyclops yeah he had
cyclops robert byrd had a 401k for for
uh whipping did he so yes grand wizard
was a these were actual rankings in the
kkk brand wizard exalted cyclops grand
giant grand dragon grand magi uh council
of the centaurs here's the thing a lot
of people don't know this it got out of
hand but really the kkk and we will this
is the more you know
it was uh
the racist thing was a front for the
fact that they were really uh the kkk
was it was a nerd dungeons and dragons
group
[Music]
man
all right now y'all remember
when we left off we were about to cross
the bog of bewilderment that's right and
when greg here you got
sorry
grand exalted cyclops got his foot stuck
in the dwarf plasma wasn't it dragon
plasm no you got that wrong i'm the
grand dragon wait hol i thought he was
the grand dragon no i'm the grand
imperial wizard wait hold up hold up
we cannot have a grand dragon a grand
imperial wizard and the grand exalted
cyclops i'm the grand imperial wizard i
called it guys it's just too many grand
it's redundant
honey
did you use my can opener again
no i didn't touch the damn can opener
josephine now for the last time we're
busy
are you guys playing that stupid
role-playing game again no we're we're
just uh
planning our next attack on the jews
yeah they run the banks yeah you got a
lot of nerve asking me that josephine
we're down here doing cleanly things now
i can't plan our next lynching if you
keep yapping
all right gee
okay fine so you're the grand dragon
you're the grand imperial wizard and
you're the grand exalted cyclops and
what am i
you're the nighthawk
a damn courier well you were the last to
join yeah but it's my house you're the
only one who has a basement we all have
soft soil and i painted the figurines
you really think i don't know what you
boys are doing down there damn it woman
we're busy down here uh
yeah they're ruining our neighborhoods
and they're uh destroying our our
society josephine i'd be of sound mind
to slap you in your smart mouth you left
your name tags up here on the counter i
can read all your stupid names name tags
uh i i got i got a new typewriter and i
thought it would be fun to make name tag
oh son of a [ __ ]
it was supposed to be a surprise i must
have left him on the table when i went
to the bathroom and forgot now you
ruined the whole damn thing and stopped
using my [ __ ] bathroom you know
you're not a real hate group right yes
we are woman we are too real hate group
we're fixing to go burn across on lyle's
lawn right now
no no no no no then we'll have to do it
it's not that hard i got the plywood
it's not about the plywood i like lyle
i'll let them know first
all right okay you get the plywood and
kerosene you call lyle
and then we'll be back here in about an
hour to finish up okay okay josephine i
hope you're hungry because you're about
to eat a mouthful of your words
[Music]
they're cross burning hot as hell
hey man them stupid ass white kids they
playing dungeons and dragons again
they're a bunch of nerds dungeons and
dragons
[Music]
how about the cross lyle our wives made
us do it well let's make you do it
golf clayton we'll be back tomorrow
clean it hey tell you what your wife's
supposed to be stopping by i got
something to fix for make sure she
stopped by i sure will me and my brother
gonna take care all right
there goes the neighborhood
so look
took a risk smash that like button
make sure that we do not stand alone in
our condemnation of the kkk that's real
totally condemned i condemn all the
racism as well as the nerdery
you just never know where things come
from just three three or four effeminate
men yeah
playing magic the gathering and it got
out of it it went crazy someone plays
the bloodlust card you're like that's a
rare card it's expensive they don't want
to trade you're not playing for keeps
look
this is what happened people don't the
black panthers it all started with pogs
i bet you we just lost three subscribers
yes we just lost three subscribers like
i don't know i don't know about this so
look i get uh i want to hear from you
guys we have more to get into in the
georgia voting let's let's do the
georgia bill uh more so or i guess the
problems with georgia voting we'll talk
about that uh tomorrow comment below if
you're look are you black
yes are you brown maybe well look if
you've answered yes to both of these
congratulations you're kamala harris but
do you think that it's racist to have a
vote right here do you have voter id and
if you want to see more uh
let us know you know we're coming back
in the new year what do you want to see
more if you want to see more of these
sketches with uh cameos do you want to
see more uh just red meat some people
you know they want this to just be like
an am radio show but she's thinking
we're about to play gay or sleigh on the
mug club smash that like button if
you're rumble you hit that button it's
okay you don't need to hit it right now
there tim the twin okay all right
smash the rumble button just like every
mayor smashes come on harrison oh
youtube right now we love you we'll see
you tomorrow piss off
you